oggi vorrei capire con voi se
effettivamente il metaverso può essere
un mezzo per creare un incontro tra le
aziende e la generazione Z
Ma perché le aziende dovrebbero creare
questo incontro qual è il motivo Beh
innanzitutto la generazione Z è già un
target di clienti
per le aziende E inoltre pensate che
questo target
raccoglierà 30 miliardi di eredità entro
un paio di decadi dai Baby boomers
questo darà loro una capacità di spesa
di investimento molto molto
significativa
Oltre a questo Dobbiamo considerare che
la generazione Z non è solo il nuovo
target di clienti ma è anche il nuovo
target di dipendenti per le aziende e
qui purtroppo abbiamo dei dati che non
sono particolarmente confortanti Se
guardiamo una recente ricerca di
LinkedIn ci dice che circa il 50%
della generazione Z che si è appena
affacciata al mondo del lavoro ha
intenzione di cambiare
posto di lavoro entro un anno e che più
in generale il 55% di questa degli
intervistati dichiarano di non essere di
non sentire adeguato il workf balance
che l'azienda propongono loro durante il
colloquio
Ecco
capiamo con questi dati che se
un'azienda vuole prosperare nel futuro
deve per forza di cose legare con la
generazione Z
Ma da dove devono partire le aziende Beh
partiamo da alcuni dati facciamo un
Identikit assieme e prendiamo i dati di
un recente report di Vice Media Group
cosa dice questo report Innanzitutto uno
degli elementi caratterizzanti è la
fiducia
pensate il 90 per cento della
generazione Z ritiene di sentirsi
di fidarsi più di se stesso che degli
altri siamo in non era in cui è
possibile andare a recuperare
informazioni ovunque fare ricerche farsi
proprio opinioni e queste opinioni che
ci si crea che la generazione Z si crea
lì gli danno la confidenza di essere più
sicuri di loro stessi rispetto a quello
che riportano i media i Brand stessi e
quindi è un dato che è molto differente
rispetto alla generazione precedente
si identificano del digitale oggi
l'identità digitale è parte della
personalità dei ragazzi Considerate che
loro non conoscono un mondo senza
internet o senza i social network la
rappresentazione di se stessi in questi
mondi è veramente per loro fondamentale
Tanto più che il 52% dichiara di
sentirsi più libero di presentare se
stesso rappresentare se stesso rispetto
a il mondo reale in modo fisico
tempo libero Probabilmente questa
generazione è stata la prima ad essere
educata o quantomeno avvertita che la
felicità è diversa dal successo o meglio
il successo è diverso dalla felicità
In effetti valorizzano tantissimo il
loro tempo libero quando parlo e mi
confronto con con altri imprenditori che
quotidianamente fanno colloqui di lavoro
a giovani talenti Beh emerge sempre una
un tratto comune tutti sappiamo
benissimo che offrire
un importo a 6 cifre la promessa di un
importo a 6 cifre entro i 40 anni Beh
questa non è una motivazione sufficiente
per poter accettare i posti di lavoro Se
questo significa per il candidato dover
scendere a compromessi con il proprio
tempo libero
sostenibilità Beh la sostenibilità
soprattutto per questa generazione È un
criterio
che viene sempre applicato nei momenti
di scelta e scelta nel mondo aziendale
vuol dire acquisto ad esempio e qui
chiaramente le aziende si stanno già
muovendo lo sappiamo stanno cercando di
rappresentare come loro sono
responsabili per l'ambiente e su queste
tematiche
e infine un altro tratto lo prendiamo
dalla da quello che è successo con la
pandemia tutte le generazioni durante la
pandemia hanno capito quanto fosse
importante riuscire a coltivare le
relazioni sociali fisiche quello che è
successo è che nella generazione Z Oltre
a questo è emersa anche la necessità
quando siano in modo digitale e quando
si hanno relazioni digitali di avere un
rapporto più immersivo più interattivo
due anni di schermo 2D
ha li ha fatti diciamo le ha fatto far
nascere questa necessità di avere un
mondo tridimensionale anche quando si si
diciamo sia nel mondo digitale
ora
Chi di voi ha sentito parlare di
metaverso
Chi di voi ci ha capito qualcosa
Ok bene Io oggi non vi darò una
definizione di metaverso i tempi non
sono maturi si è appena partiti in
questo con questo nuovo Trend È tutto
ancora molto liquido però c'è una cosa
su cui un po' tutti gli esperti di
settore sono sostanzialmente d'accordo
Quali sono gli elementi che fondano il
metaverso Beh sono quattro si chiamano
metavers Technologies e in particolare
Mi riferisco al mondo dei
mondi 3D e del gaming la realtà
aumentata e la realtà virtuale
la blockchain e Digital asset gli nft e
l'intelligenza artificiale generativa di
cui stiamo sentendo parlare molto spesso
nelle ultime nelle ultime settimane
Ecco le aziende molte aziende oggi
stanno usando queste tecnologie le metto
per Technologies per cercare di creare
un ponte con la generazione Z che oggi è
ancora troppo lontana da loro ci sono
molti esempi ne proviamo a guardare
qualcuno assieme ad esempio nel mondo
industriale della della moda del fashion
del beauty ci sono moltissimi esempi di
aziende che stanno costruendo dei
prodotti esclusivamente digitali e che
cercano di vendere
Ci sono diversi modi con cui lo fanno
c'è chi crea delle collezioni uniche
cercando di renderle diciamo
esclusive avere pochi pezzi e in qualche
maniera creare l'iPad questo questo
oggetto C'è chi lo fa
mettendoli in Combo prendo il prodotto
fisico e ti do anche quello digitale
cosiddetto Digital Twin altri che
regalano il prodotto digitale in cambio
di esperienze fisiche fatte in Ad
esempio in negozio Cosa gli accomuna li
accomuna che tutti comunque a
prescindere dalla modalità vogliono
cercare di dare la generazione Z un modo
di personalizzare il proprio Avatar il
proprio
digitale che sappiamo essere tanto
importante per la generazione Z
un altro esempio molto comune è quello
delle delle Community molto spesso
aziende soprattutto aziende di prodotto
stanno cercando di far partecipare al
processo di creazione di un nuovo
prodotto
le nuove generazioni come lo fanno lo
fanno con su nuovi canali tipo discord è
uno dei più conosciuti Oggi dove la
generazione Z Si
si diverte ad aggregarsi ad avere degli
scambi delle comunicazioni e Appunto
questa generazione Z può diciamo
partecipare a dei contest partecipare
alla creazione e in cambio ottenere o
delle esperienze esclusive o addirittura
una quota derivante dalla vendita poi
del prodotto una volta lanciato
l'esperienza in Game Ecco qui diciamo
che
per chi di voi è appassionato di gioco
si sarà reso conto che c'è sempre di più
le aziende sono all'interno di questa
esperienza penso ad esempio a
giochi che sono abbastanza famosi in
questo periodo ad esempio Roblox ad
esempio fortnite Ecco ci sono tantissime
aziende che sono lì dentro immaginatevi
istituti finanziari che
promuovono fanno e promuovono il loro
gioco di educazione finanziaria
recentemente ho letto di un'azienda
della grande distribuzione supermercati
che ha creato una propria un proprio
spazio all'interno di uno di questi
giochi molto famosi e con lo scopo di
dare all'utente che fosse in grado di
raccogliere diciamo dei prodotti
sostenibili che questa azienda propone
avrebbe guadagnato più vita e quindi il
gioco sarebbe durato più a lungo
rispetto a quello che si trova
normalmente Quando si gioca
e ci sono tantissimi altri esempi
molti di voi saranno abituati a
utilizzare Instagram Snapchat in
particolare i filtri Ecco le aziende
stanno cercando di utilizzare una
tecnologia simile basata sulle iar
chiamata Virtual triion per fare cosa
per provare attraverso un telefonino a
indossare a vestire capi accessori borse
e scarpe
proprio Senza doverli provare
fisicamente ma digitalmente con quale
beneficio Beh ad esempio Se parlavamo
prima di sostenibilità sicuramente un
beneficio è quello durante il percorso
di acquisto online il fatto di poter
provare questi prodotti in questo modo
riduce il numero di Resi con un impatto
significativo
un altro esempio ancora eventi molte
aziende stanno cercando di capire come
far diventare un evento una fiera che a
cui sono
soliti partecipare fallo diventare
virtuale per evitare di dover spostare
centinaia migliaia centinaia di migliaia
di persone da una da una location ad
un'altra
generazione Z non solo clienti abbiamo
detto anche dipendenti una delle
primissime cose che succederà a voi che
vi state per affacciare al mondo del
futuro al mondo del lavoro o chi di voi
l'ha già fatto è di dover fare
soprattutto i primi giorni molti corsi
molto training che è assolutamente
importante ma sappiamo a volte anche un
po' noioso
molte Crocette per arrivare aspettando
di arrivare all'ultima e diciamo fatti
in maniera un po' meccanica Ecco ci sono
degli Studi che dimostrano che
virtualizzare questi corsi e diciamo
staccandosi dalla logica di slide e test
Crocetta ma creando delle simulazioni
all'interno della vettoriality
L'emozione che si provano che si riesce
a provare durante questo questo modalità
di fare Trading cementificano quello che
è
l'apprendimento quattro volte superiore
rispetto allo standard diciamo corso che
si può fare pensate al vantaggio che si
potrebbe avere quando si fa un corso
importantissimo come corso della salute
della sicurezza Quando si inizia a
lavorare fatto in questo modo simulato e
non soltanto Crocette aspettando che
finisca il prima possibile
bene A questo punto
prima di lasciarvi vi voglio fare Vi
lascio con un quesito Vi faccio una
domanda se doveste essere voi a creare
una relazione con le aziende oggi quali
tentativi faresti
usereste le metastasi
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]